what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
and today i had the
awesome opportunity of attending the
loki
press conference footage of the loki
press conference is not allowed to be
posted but i can talk about everything
they talked about so that's what this
video is breaking down
everything that was discussed all of the
questions that were asked and all of the
answers that were given during the loki
press conference by tom hiddleston
owen wilson kevin feige and the rest of
the cast and crew and of course tomorrow
night i'll be doing my watch parties
again
for loki hope to see everybody out there
again and hope to have a great time like
we have for the past two
mcu disney plush shows so let's dive
into and break down
this press conference now in the show
you'll see that owen wilson
and tom hiddleston have amazing
chemistry together
their scenes together are brilliant and
hilarious but there are also
some very emotional aspects to loki and
owen wilson's mobius helps him get there
so one of the questions to both tom and
owen wilson
was if they did anything to develop
their chemistry and bond and dylan
wilson said
i think it was really this sort of
before we started filming
tom very generously and patiently taking
me through the mcu mythology
letting me ask questions i think that
was really helpful and really important
to our dynamic filming the scenes where
we're going over that stuff
that was really important to me going to
loki school
and then tom hiddleston said it was such
an interesting time
trying to compress the experience of my
time in the mcu
six movies and mobius is an expert in
loki he knows more about loki
than loki does owen asked such
insightful
intelligent questions that made me
rethink various aspects of the character
our conversations found their way into
the scenes themselves
and their interactions because they're
quite intense conversations
at one point owen was like this kind of
feels a
bit like a play i think maybe there was
a germ of an idea that settled in owen's
mind that a theatrical experience might
be coming around the corner
in which owen wilson replied it was
always sort of a chess match between
mobius and loki
logie is just clearly playing ketchup i
thought that the scenes they were fun to
do
they were long scenes that's where it
started to feel like a play
i think they have some tension and humor
and this is all fantastic to hear
because i think you'll all find as you
watch the loki series
specifically the very first episode in a
couple of days you'll find that the
relationship between these two
characters
really make the show combined with all
of the other relationships as well
now owen wilson absolutely crushes his
character he really did an
excellent job and he was asked how much
it took to convince him
to join the superhero world of the mcu
in which he said it didn't take too much
convincing it was really the
conversation
kate who was the director and i had that
was a comprehensive phone call
where kate walked me through the idea
for the show and the dynamic between
mobius and loki
i think i signed on right then and i'm
really glad he did
and you will all see why very soon now
as most people already know
loki is going to talk about time travel
and the multiverse and
alternate timelines being created it's a
really really big part of the show
and today in an interview with empire
magazine kevin feige the president of
marvel studios
said that loki will have more of an
impact on the mcu
than any of the other shows so far and
he also said that it's tremendously
important and that's coming from the big
man the president of marvel studios
himself and keep in mind kevin feige
oversees everything
the grand story of the mcu the direction
that it heads towards
is kevin feige's direction of course he
has amazing people by him but he is in
charge and basically he's saying that
loki is the most
important disney plus show so far which
leads me to believe that this is really
the start of
the multiverse and i think it's really
going to start to fall apart
by the end of loki i think it will
definitely fall apart but in the press
conference today he was asked if it was
tough to balance time periods and
timelines
in which he said early on it was sort of
the low-hanging fruit
there was ideas for a short film going
back almost a decade for loki running a
studio 54 in the 70s i think we had some
concept art of him on a horse
thankfully thanks to michael and kate
the story became more interesting than
that
which of course became about the tva and
multiple different timelines
now one of the big things that everybody
knows because this is obviously a
different loki than the one who died
in avengers infinity war spoiler alert
one of the things is discovering what
kind of arc
this character is going to have because
he hasn't yet been through the
experiences
that the other loki did to make him
let's say good
so right now he's still very much the
god of mischief and he hasn't
let's say matured yet so one of the
questions asked to tom
was what does he personally want the
audience to take away from his
character's arc
in the show and this is what he said
what i love about the series
is loki is stripped of everything that's
familiar to him
thor is not close by asgard seems some
distance away
the avengers for the time being aren't
in sight
he's stripped of his status and his
power if you take
all of those things loki has used to
identify himself
over the last 6 movies what remains of
loki
who is he within or outside of those
things
i think those questions for all of us
became really fascinating to ask
is he capable of growth is he capable of
change
do his experiences with the tva give him
insight
to who he might be i hope the audience
gets a kick
out of where we might go and just
judging off of the first two episodes i
would say yes we are definitely going to
get a kick
out of where it's going to go he very
much is the old
loki in the very beginning but his
character becomes very grounded
very early on because like he said he is
stripped
of everything he is captured by the tva
and of course they have a very specific
purpose for him which is also going to
reveal a lot about who loki truly
is on the inside now owen wilson did
talk about
the secrecy that comes with being a part
of the mcu
when he was welcomed onto the press
conference by the moderator he said
it's exciting to be a part of the mcu
seeing the trailer start to come out and
how excited people get
the secrecy surrounding this i didn't
quite understand
until i saw that the fan base is so
revved up
and passionate and marvel's just so
committed to trying to surprise people
so then you get into it and he then went
on to even admit that he is still
walking on eggshells trying not to spoil
anything about the show
and then he said but there are some very
shocking things that are going to happen
in the series and if you think about
this
really loki is the future of the mcu
everything that is happening is
affecting what they've called the sacred
timeline and we've seen it called that
in some trailers so
it's not a spoiler but the sacred
timeline is essentially the main
mcu timeline and if you're asking if the
series addresses
why loki is getting in trouble for time
travel and the avengers didn't
yes it does address it and it addresses
it in a way that i think some people
will really enjoy but i think some
people
won't i personally am like okay sure but
i think some people might have a hard
time dealing with the answer
like why didn't steve get in trouble for
going back in time
and living with peggy carter but loki
gets in trouble don't worry
they answer that and a final interesting
note that actually came from kevin feige
was the fact that when loki
died in avengers infinity war he
actually did not know that they were
going to do a loki series they had not
planned that yet
he said that they didn't know this show
would be coming when they started
working on infinity war but
they did know when they developed the
story point where loki disappears an end
game so when loki died in infinity war
they didn't know that they were actually
going to make a loki series they hadn't
decided that yet but in avengers in-game
they did know what they were going to do
so that's why loki escaped so he could
go on to set up the loki series which is
going to be
an insanely important and awesome series
it was awesome to be a part of the press
conference i didn't get to ask a
question this time because there are
just
a ton of different outlets trying to ask
questions but i did get a one-on-one
interview with the head writer michael
waldron and hopefully that video will be
up tomorrow i have to wait till disney
sends it to me
but in the meantime don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on
anything relating to loki and the mcu
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me